voilà pour l'audition de françois
villeroy de galhau qui a été hier
entendu par les sénateurs de la
commission des finances les sénateurs
qui avaient accordé énormément
d'importance à cette audition puisque
d'ailleurs tout l'après midi ils avaient
entendu des experts pour se faire une
idée sur cette question notamment y at
il un conflit d'intérêts un problème une
contradiction a nommé un ancien patron
de la bnp paribas à la tête du l'une des
principales institutions de régulation
bancaire la banque de france ils ont
répondu qu'il n'y avait pas de
contradiction puisqu'ils ont approuvé
cette nomination à une très large
majorité
il faut dire que françois villeroy de
galhau tout au long de cette audition a
montré toute sa motivation a rappelé son
indépendance a également indiqué qu'il
avait toujours souhaité montrer son
attachement au service public tout au
long de sa carrière voilà pour cette
audition je vous propose tout de suite
de revenir à une autre audition
l'audition qui se tient depuis ce matin
à la commission des lois à celle de jean
jacques hyest qui est le candidat de
gérard larcher pour être nommée au
conseil constitutionnel tout de suite
donc retour à cette audition mes chers
collègues la séance
est ouverte
nous allons procéder à l'audition de
monsieur jean jacques hyest
je me demande s'il est vraiment utile de
le présenter
mais plutôt que de parler de lui
je voudrais vous dire
quel est le portrait robot
de mon point de vue et sans me hisser au
dessus de ma condition
du membre du conseil constitutionnel
désigné
par le président du sénat
dans le meilleur des cas il doit s'agir
d'un parlementaire chevronné
et ce parlementaire de s'être illustré
par ses compétences juridiques
son souci de la défense des libertés sa
connaissance de l'état
ledit parlementaire s'il a été président
de la commission des lois a évidemment
des titres supplémentaires à faire
valoir
surtout quand il a présidé la commission
avec une maîtrise que tout le monde lui
a reconnu et une connaissance des
branches du droit les plus variés allant
du droit civil du droit des sociétés du
droit pénal du droit de la procédure
pénale au droit public au droit
constitutionnel
le bon
candidat pressenti par le président du
sénat doit aussi être un homme
indépendant
un homme de caractère
un homme d'autorité
et un homme qui serait tout en étant bon
connaisseur de l'assemblée nationale un
ardent défenseur du bicamérisme
et qui se soit
illustré
dans la cause du bicamérisme pendant de
nombreuses années je vous laisse juge
après toutefois que vous ayez pu poser
des questions aux candidats pressentis
par le président larcher de savoir si
notre ami jean jacques hyest réunit tout
ou partie de ses qualités et je lui
laisse la parole pour présenter
les raisons qui le poussent lui même qui
le pousserait à accepter
si la proposition lui été confirmé si
notre commission ne s'y opposer par
là l'éventualité de rejoindre le conseil
constitutionnel je dois dire que pour
nous ce serait évidemment une grande
perte mais ce n'est pas une raison
suffisante pour le retenir de force dans
notre assemblée et dans notre commission
des lois et georges actuelle à paroles
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ce n'est pas la première fois
que vous avez à vous prononcer sur une
nomination au conseil constitutionnel
les c'est la première fois qu'un membre
de la commission des lois est proposée
par le président larcher
ce qui me laure infiniment après tant
d'années j'ai consacré modestement a
participé à l'élaboration de la loi
qu'il me soit permis tout d'abord de
rendre hommage aux qualités
intellectuelles et morales d'hubert
haenel grand serviteur de l'état et du
droit
mais qui avait été longtemps près de
membres de la commission des lois
dont je serais si vous le souhaitez
appelés à finir le mandat il est d'usagé
de se présenter en brossant rapidement
le parcours qui peut justifier une
nomination dans cette haute instance je
serai relativement bref sur ce point car
j'ai partagé avec beaucoup d'entre vous
à l'assemblée
comme
au sénat une grande partie de ses
bientôt trente années qu'il était
ministre responsable des institutions
dans lesquelles j'ai siégé ou
parlementaire je devrais dire
législateur fidèles à leur mandat j'ai
beaucoup appris à leur contact
après des études de droit classique à la
faculté de droit et des sciences
économiques de paris
avant que les facultés un numéro
auprès de m éminents comme le doyen
vedel les professeurs hors ue bastide
raynaud pierre henri teitgen et rivero
et bien entendu raymond barre
enfin pour qui je garde un profond
respect et qui m'a encouragé à m'engager
dans la vie publique
la vie est en fait de rencontres celle
du président etienne dailly dont le
souvenir est très présent dans cette
assemblée vous conduisez à m'intéresser
particulièrement aux collectivités
locales comme directeur des services du
conseil général de seine et marne puis
aux questions de sécurité civile de ce
département auquel vous savez je suis
très attaché
particulièrement aux gâtinais
latine s est une région merveilleuse
terre de miel je vous le rappelle dans
toute ma famille est issu et du
conseiller général en 82 jusqu'en mars
dernier puis maire d'un village un
charmant village la madeleine sur loin
mais c'est pas un village pêcheurs c'est
pas du tout en 1983 et vous savez
c'est là où on apprend aussi beaucoup de
choses et pour mieux légiférer le jour
où il n'y aura plus de parlementaires
élus locaux je crains quand même pour
l'amélioration de notre législation
j'étais amené à mettre en oeuvre la loi
de décentralisation de 2 du 2 mars 1982
véritable bouleversement pour les
départements et c'était pour moi une
époque une époque
enthousiasmante auprès d'un autre
sénateur
paul cérami maire de fontainebleau dont
j'avais été l'élève au lycée quel
challenge pour les élus de ce
département dont la population a presque
doublé en trente ans
ayant été encouragée à me présenter aux
élections législatives de 86 avec le
soutien actif de raymond barre c'est à
la commission des lois après cette
élection et jusqu'en 1995 date de mon
entrée au sénat levé syrie sans
discontinuer et apprenant le métier de
législateurs je voudrais citer quelques
lois qui m'ont marqué comme la loi
chevènement mais nous en avons eu depuis
beaucoup d'autres sur les collectivités
locales loi raffarin celle de 2010 dont
je me souviendrai longtemps aussi sur
les collectivités locales les lois
pasqua sur la sécurité et sur
l'immigration mais je retiendrai une
réforme majeure celle du code pénal dont
j'ai eu l'honneur de rapporter le livre
2 sur les atteintes aux biens plusieurs
mois de débats je pense au débat sur
l'article 40 de l'ancien code pénal sur
l'irresponsabilité pour démence nous
avions cru améliorer les choses on
s'était un peu trompé c'était des débats
passionnés et passionnants un dialogue
constructif entre l'assemblée et le
sénat qui ont permis de bâtir cet
ensemble cohérent
hélas un peu érodé depuis notamment en
ce qui concerne l'échelle des peines
depuis mon entrée en scène en septembre
95 venu à la commission des lois sous la
houlette du président jacques larcher
autorité reconnue dans cette maison et
en parcourant la centaine de rapports
que j'ai pu présenter je mesure le
chemin parcouru et je vous éviterait une
numération
ça fait cependant qu'en dehors du droit
des collectivités locales mars est
marquée récemment par la loi dit notre
dont j'ai partagé le poids avec mon ami
rené van d'irène donc c'est le droit
civil et le droit commercial mais aussi
les outre mer qui vont toujours
passionné bien entendu le droit
constitutionnel et organique
j'ai été rapporteur de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 le droit pénal
la procédure pénale mais je pourrais
citer tous qui nous occupe tous les ce
qui est notre lot quotidien
où j'ai essayé de toujours m'intéresser
à tous les sujets c'est pas toujours
facile parce que la commission des lois
est parfois surchargées si je devais
faire un bilan collectif
pas seulement bien des apports de la
commission des lois du sénat je citerai
la loi pénitentiaire
qui même si elle souffre de difficultés
de mise en oeuvre a été un grand moment
de consensus politique
changeant l'esprit de la détention
ce ne fut possible qu'à la suite de la
commission d' enquête menée sur ce sujet
en 2000 le président bada terre et jean
rené lecerf fpt en furent les fervents
soutiens
qu'il me soit permis enfin de citer
quelques réformes importantes ou le
sénat a porté sa marque
la sauvegarde des entreprises en
difficulté mais surtout la réforme des
successions et libéralités et celle des
prescriptions en matière civile cette
dernière réforme il faut rappeler qu'ils
paraissent impossibles
est issue d'un rapport sénatorial que
j'avais rédigé avec une portelli et
richard llung
ce qui m'a permis ensuite de déposer une
proposition de loi qui a conduit à cette
réforme importante pour la sécurité
juridique c'est dire aussi que
l'initiative parlementaire peut être
pertinente
et que l'on ne peut que regretter que la
réforme des contrats des obligations
soit réglé par ordonnance ce que le
sénat avait refusé à la quasi unanimité
au moment où si vous le décidez je vais
quitter le parlement
pour rejoindre une institution qui est
certes parfois critiqués mais dont le
rôle s'est affirmée notamment avec la
réforme de 2008
qui a créé la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité il y avait eu une
tentative précédente que j'avais soutenu
le président robert badinter voulait
déjà instauré ce contrôle de
constitutionnalité je considère qu'il
est opportun mais le président baladi
que d'anciens parlementaires siègent au
conseil constitutionnel c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'a voulu le président larcher me
l'a dit en me proposant
outre le respect formel de la
constitution est en vigilance sur l'
équilibre des pouvoirs entre l'exécutif
et le législatif
et en y apportant mon expérience du
bicamérisme qui est d'autant plus
précieux que l'institution du
quinquennat et la concomitance de
l'élection présidentielle et des
élections législatives
a changé beaucoup de choses
soyez assurés j'aurai à coeur de faire
respecter les droits légitimes du
parlement et le bicamérisme
certains se plaint que l'on gilles
légifère trop mais à qui la faute
et trop lentement
comme si la procédure accélérée qui peut
se justifier pour certains textes plus
technique était la panacée alors qu'elle
ne permet pas un véritable dialogue
entre les deux assemblées et devant le
pays
bien entendu et c'est le coeur de la
mission du conseil constitutionnel le
respect des principes fondamentaux
reconnus par les lois de la république
et plus généralement les libertés
publiques et la libre administration des
collectivités locales qui vont toujours
guidé dans l'examen des textes
législatifs
quelles que soient les majorités quelles
que soient les majorités
continueront inspiré ma réflexion et mon
action
puisque bientôt je serai peut-être
privés de parole publique
et de tout mandat électoral
je voudrais remercier chaleureusement
tous ceux qui m'ont aidé et encouragé
particulièrement les présidents de la
commission des lois les présidents de
groupe
mais aussi
les admirables collaborateurs de la
commission est généralement tout le
personnel du sénat
je regretterai bien entendu vos nos
débats parfois vifs pré crise c'est
quelquefois tendance à m'impatienter
mais toujours empreints du respect des
personnes qui est une marque de la
civilité qui règne dans cette assemblée
et qui est précieuse les longues heures
passées à élaborer la meilleure loi
possible
j'ai été très heureux
comme élu local et comme parlementaire
mais il ne faut pas céder à la nostalgie
et comme le répétait la grande thérèse
d'avila allons en avant
mes chers collègues
je n'ai aucune question à poser
à jean jacques hyest
mais je suis certain que plusieurs
d'entre vous ne résisteront pas à la
tentation
de l'inviter à s'exprimer davantage
et c'est le cas de pierre yves collombat
c'est le président je vous rappeler
comme ça je serais pas votre éloge ça
serait un peu long je vais simplement
vous vous interrogez enfin vous vous
demandez ce que vous pensez
de la jurisprudence constante jusqu'à ce
jour où à peu près constante du conseil
constitutionnel
on sait bien pourquoi le conseil
constitutionnel a été créé c'est un
outil anti parlementaire
qui a été qu'ils étaient censés
corriger c'est mon interprétation qui
était censé corriger les excès du
parlementarisme non rationaliser
ce ses hôtes y est continuant à être
utilisé sans sans défaillir au moment où
on est arrivé au bout du bout un parle
d'un parlementarisme que je me plais
appelé lyophilisés est ce qu'il faudrait
pas un peu faire évoluer les choses
parce que s'il y a des équilibre des
pouvoirs c'est au détriment des
législatifs on constate tous les jours
donc est ce que ça change sans parler à
changer de constitution ce n'est pas le
rôle feu du conseil constitutionnel vous
ne pensez pas qu'on pourrait quand même
faire évoluer la législation dans un
sens qui rééquilibre ans justement les
pouvoirs permettrait à cette
constitution de continuer à fonctionner
sous d'autres cieux dans d'autres
circonstances et c'est pour le bien le
bien de la nation
ce président oui ah oui mais enfin il ya
un certain nombre de choses il faudrait
une révision de la constitution veuillez
m'excuser parce que si on veut vraiment
changer les choses c'est comme ça on a
une constitution
qui est effectivement qui voulait le
parlementarisme rationalisé bon
je suis pas complètement d'accord avec
vous sur la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel
je m'attacherai si vous le permettez si
vous aussi vous
d'accepter la proposition du président a
rappelé aussi quand même que le
parlement a des droits et que c'est c
est notamment le sénat mais vous savez
il ya une jurisprudence récente
extrêmement intéressante rappelez-vous
le lait les amendements déposés en
commission en séance ou en commission
l'assemblée nous avait dit pas question
toute façon c'était en commission donc
ça n'a aucune valeur pas du tout le
conseil constitutionnel dit d'ailleurs
si on réfléchit bien ça ne voudrait rien
dire que les amendements déposés en
séance ou en commission puisque on
délibère désormais sur le texte de la
commission ça ne voudrait plus rien dire
si on est retenaient pas pour les
reprendre éventuellement après cmp ou
wii lors des dernières lectures
je sais que alors moi je rappelle aussi
quand même que globalement et il faut
toujours se souvenir que c'est le
président du sénat
en
1978 c'est ça en 1978 qui a déposé un
recours c'était pour le droit
d'association
à
70,70
1,70 et ça quand même déclenché
désormais toute une jurisprudence avec
les jets 10 des droits flée les droits
fondamentaux
reconnus par les lois de la république
donc moi je pense quand même qu'il ya
une
ça ne s'appelait pas quand c'est censuré
alors est-ce que
l'application de l'article 34 et 37
c'est une notion assez floue et qui n'a
jamais alors c'est vrai que dans les
premières années du conseil c'était ce
qu'ils contrôlaient nouveau empiéter sur
le domaine réglementaire
après le conseil a dit vous vous faites
ce que vous voulez mais il des classes
d'ailleurs temps en temps il des classes
des mesures qu'ils ont et qui avaient
été prises dans le domaine qui a été
prise par le législateur dans le domaine
réglementaire
on peut regretter cette situation
je pense que
je vous le dis le rôle du conseil
constitutionnel depuis d'instauration de
la qpc a beaucoup changé les choses
parce que il s'attache qui va -
s'attacher
à la régularité formelle il aura dit
gardera sa jurisprudence sur la résultat
a été formel des textes mais qui va nous
inciter à
regarder si dans le passé nous avons
bien respecté les normes
constitutionnelles et ça c'est très
important
d'ailleurs on l'a vu je vous le rappelle
lorsqu'il concerne la garde à vue
même si la cour de cassation a dit avec
vous témoin il faut aller plus vite
c'est parce que parce que moi je
j'assure le contrôle de conventionnalité
ce qui est un petit problème que nous
avions essayé
que nous avions abordé lors de la
révision de 2008
sans vraiment trouver une solution parce
que vous avez quand même
d'ailleurs peut-être même
le problème de la saisine un but du
conseil constutionnel certains parlent
de l'étang de l'ouvrier enfin je lis des
choses à partir du moment où justement
du conseil je ne ferai plus de
commentaires sur ces sujets
merci monsieur le président monsieur
michel mercier
ça m'étonne pas pour cette somme mais
c'est bon
voilà je suis heureux aujourd'hui
ah oui tout à fait je résume m lamé et
je voulais plus près de toi
pour une raison simple c'est que voir
jean jacques est probablement dans
quelques instants membre du conseil
constitutionnel
c'est pour un certain nombre de membres
de cette assemblée est une vraie joie on
se connaît depuis très longtemps
l'assemblée au sénat dans des formations
politiques ou aux amis les mêmes
fonctions donc
moi je voudrais poser jean jacques hyest
de questions il nous a rappelé cet
attachement au bicamérisme qui est
profond
quand on regarde sa carrière l'assemblée
ou ici on s'aperçoit aussi qu'il a été
toujours le défenseur des libertés
publiques je pense pour ma part que un
des fondements et des raisons bête du
bicamérisme et du rôle du sénat c'est la
défense des libertés publiques
c'est ce qui justifie qu'il seconde
chambre farce la chambre i knew suffrage
direct et il est nécessaire qu'ils
deuxième chambre qu'ils puissent être
défenseurs des libertés publiques le
conseil constitutionnel
est certes dans la constitution de 1958
un organe régulateur de l'activité des
pouvoirs publics plus qu'autre chose
mais des évolutions vous jean-jacques a
rappelé la saisie du président paul
hertz au droit d'association
et c'est quelque chose d'important
est-ce que la conception de conduire à
renforcer
au sein du conseil constitutionnel
défense des libertés publiques et pas
simplement s'en tenir à la régulation de
l'activité normative des pouvoirs
publics c'est la première question est
la seconde question on voit se
développer notamment côté de la cour de
cassation
l'idée de cour suprême nouvelle et
j'aimerais qu'ils nous disent peut-être
parce qu'il faudra mais ses idées et
général sur ce point
l esi monsieur président oui michel
mercier effectivement se connaît depuis
très longtemps on a partagé beaucoup de
choses
bien entendu je les dis le c'est drôle à
mon avis aujourd'hui j'ai dit les
régulations des pouvoirs publics même si
on peut temps dont on peut râler parce
que un amendement a été retoqué mais je
crois que c'est quand même pas ça le
plus important je les dis les libertés
publiques
j'ai c'est un professeur rivero qui
m'enseignait les libertés publiques y en
a d'autres dans cette salle c'est
formidable c'était formidable
mais on en est resté marqué par le et
je crois que le conseil il l'a fait
quand même parce que rappelez vous la
décision sur la garde à vue qu'on veut
quand même les droits de la défense les
haies etc
c'est quand même avant c'était on avait
en avait il y avait des pots il y avait
des commandes des hostilités forte
rappelez vous
l'appelez policiers aude-claire disait
ça va être horrible
l'avocat à la première heure en garde à
vue ça va être horrible bon bah en fin
de compte bon ça
mais c'est sale et garantie des libertés
publiques
toutes les libertés la vie privée
mais pas je vais pas tous les citer
parce que je reprendrai un cours de
droit mais c'est vraiment moi je pense
je les dis d'ailleurs un ca me parait tu
la mission prioritaire
du conseil constitutionnel j'allais dire
aussi dans les qpc aussi dans les qpc et
vous savez alors pour la deuxième
question qu'on le veuille ou non la qpc
iran et à instaurer sa chance de mon
point de vue la nature du conseil et ça
leur approche quand même d'une cour
suprême et que la cour de cassation
veille revendiqué
mais ça c'est pas nouveau bon
moi je pense que on a un système
la cour le conséquences sociales n'est
pas cour suprême mais il s'en rapproche
il s'en rapproche
parce que à cause de l'institution de la
qpc de mon point de vue
monsieur jean yves le conte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président d'abord je voudrais vous dire
combien j'ai apprécié été impressionné
par
la manière dont vous avez participé à la
commission des lois lorsque j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être membre de la commission
des lois et vu comment vous travaillez
sur les sujets en particulier sujet de
de libertés publiques en toute
indépendance
j'aurais posé une question par rapport à
la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel qui parfois s'inscrit en
contradiction
du droit européen un peu indirectement
des choses qui viennent d'être évoqués
pensez vous que dans ces cas là on doit
en rester le conseil constitutionnel
doit rester à sa jurisprudence ou dès
lors qu'à partir du à partir du moment
où il apparaît que notre doigt droit
évoluer parce que la cour de justice de
l'union européenne en a décidé autrement
faut-il que ce soit intégrée dans les la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
doit elle évoluer à ce moment là on a un
certain nombre de contentieux fiscaux
actuellement sur ce plan et comment vous
voyez ces choses
je vais donner tout de suite la part de
madame tasca parce que je vois que leur
avancée elle la demande est peut-être
pourrez-vous après que monsieur
richard aura lui aussi posé une question
répondent aux trois aux trois dernières
questions
globalement donc madame tasca puis
monsieur richard et pas d'autres
questions je n'en vois pas je veux
ajouter à l'éloge qui a été prononcé ici
à l'égard de notre collègue le président
y est si je devais résumer mon sentiment
à son égard c'est vraiment le respect
parce que depuis des années j'ai vu
comment il exerce
son mandat et comment ils contribuent à
un aux travaux
monsieur le président vous allez changer
de monde en entend au conseil
constitutionnel une grande
caractéristique je pense de votre
manière d'être c'est votre indépendance
d'esprit qui s'ajoute évidemment à vos
compétences et à vos connaissances dans
la manière dont fonctionne le conseil
constitutionnel
il me semble que le changement le plus
patent c'est qu'il ya une certaine
solitude des membres du conseil
constitutionnel
qui ne bénéficient pas de ce qui fait
ici notre assurance notre confort je
dirais c'est à dire
le concours d'administrateur d'une très
très grande compétence et dans l'examen
des dossiers au conseil constitutionnel
très souvent me semble-t-il c'est
l'administration le secrétariat général
qui
encadrent de très près les choix les
prises de position des membres du
conseil alors je voudrais vous demander
de garder au sein du conseil vous avez
dit que vous seriez privé de votre
capacité d'expression publique c'est
bien naturel mais j'espère que au sein
de ce collège vous garderez en revanche
toute votre liberté de débat et que vous
saurez
défendre ce que sont vos idées vos
analyses pour ne pas être
d'une certaine manière
neutraliser ou ou limitée dans votre
capacité
d'influencer les les décisions par les
positions de l'administration du conseil
merci cher collègue monsieur alain
richard
ma question me rappelle la réflexion du
de jean jacques hyest poursuit un tout
petit peu ce que disait catherine tasca
l'instant parce que ce qui me
semble-t-il
contribuer à une certaine autorité du
conseil constitutionnel c'est la réalité
de sa collégialité
et puisque tu veux qu'elle la cour
suprême mais ce qui me frappe beaucoup
c'est que quand quelqu'un entre à la
cour suprême aux états unis tous les
états unis savent comment il va voter
sur tous les sujets
et donc une partie du jeu politique dans
cette belle démocratie consiste
simplement à
apprécier le potentiel démographique de
chacun des membres de la cour suprême
parce que ont un mandat défini
de manière à regarder quel équilibre
entre des tendances préétabli et ce qui
me frappe beaucoup et ce qui me fait
pour ma part être un défenseur du
conseil constitutionnel c'est que à
travers un mécanisme nomination qui est
optiquement purement politique nous
voyons le conseil
prendre des options prendre les
inflexions de sa jurisprudence ou des
initiatives qui ne sont absolument pas
l'addition des positions qu'on pourrait
prêter par leur passé à chacun des
membres
est évidemment le mécanisme de ces
auditions préalable à la nomination
vient peu en contradiction avec ça parce
que on essaye de faire dire par avance
un futur membre du conseil
constitutionnel comment il entend voter
sur chacun des sujets et même on peut on
pourrait presque entendre derrière
certaines questions la passation d'une
commande en disant ça serait bien que
vous vous étiez dans tel ou tel sens et
non il me semble que si cette
institution peut
garder dix ont une crédibilité que je
croirais l'a conquise
c'est parce que les gens s'écoute les
gens débattent il ne bavarde pas
l'extérieur
quand on voit quand même tout ce qui est
passé devant le conseil constitutionnel
depuis cinquante et quelques années il
ya quand même pas beaucoup de
confidences répandu en disant moi
j'aurais préféré ceci ou cela et je
pense d'ailleurs que ce serait une grave
erreur de développer parce que c'est
parfois suggéré l'expression publique
d'opinions dissidentes sur ce qui a été
voté ou pas par le conseil est donc pour
ma part il me semble que la proche qui
est celle de jean jacques hyest cadre
parfaitement avec cette conception
merci cher collègue monsieur le
président y est vous avez la parole
même la présidente à ce qu'avait d'abord
dans le genre je compte
je joue les dix
lorsque nous avons débattu de la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008
on s'est posé le problème de la
conventionalité
et de la constitutionnalité alors pour
le droit de l'union il est pas il n'est
pas conventionnel a failli puisque les
règlements s'appliquent directement déjà
dans notre
ordonnancement juridique et il n'est pas
question pour le conseiller social de
les contrôler
mais il se développe de plus en plus et
c'est heureux c'est je vous souhaite que
ça se poursuive c'est des questions
préjudicielles
c'est à dire on renvoie à la cour
justice les questions qui sont posées
question préjudicielle c'est quand même
pas mal ça devrait permettre quand même
d'éviter ce qu'il ya
lady il peut y avoir des contradictions
entre
les conventions
et la constituent pas de contradiction
globalement parce que quand même là dire
là la déclaration universelle des droits
de l'homme où la déclaration européenne
des droits de l'homme quand même c'est à
peu près les principes que des il ya
deux siècles la france avait développé
donc je crois quand même que mais par où
pourrait se poser des questions aussi
sur la jurisprudence de la cedh et aph
non mes messages et pas dessus pas de de
réponse à cette question la présente à
ce cas je ne connais pas encore le
conseil de l'intérieur non je pourrais
vous dire que d'abord il ya quand même
quelques moyens
il faut pas qu'il soit univoque bien
entendu mais
j'ai pas
comment
j'ai pas l'habitude de me faire mener
pour décider ce que j'ai envie de faire
et donc je défendrai comme je voulais
dit comme je les ai toujours fait d'une
manière libre qui me paraît correspondre
à aux valeurs que nous devons défendre
et je les dis aussi au respect des
droits du parlement je le ferai toujours
et je défendrai mes positions
est jeune on j'essaierai de convaincre
mes collègues dont certains sont peu ne
connaissent pas ce qui fait la richesse
d'un parlement vraiment de latin ils
l'ont vu de l'extérieur c'est des gens
éminents mais ils ont besoin un petit
peu de se frotter avec allée des gens
qui sont peu être moins diplômées mais
qui ont plus de réalisme et puis qui en
fin de compte connaît mieux les râles la
réalité des choses
voilà et quentin harris a derrière tout
ça posait la question en fait je résume
à est-ce qu'il faut des opinions
dissidentes c'est ça parce que c'est là
c'est le terme non
ça serait complètement alors ça rendrait
puisque le but je crois que c'est vrai
d'ailleurs on exagère un peu je crois
que le débat me semble-t-il ce que ça on
en parle quand même avec des bandes du
conseil constitutionnel pas sur les
décisions mais sur l'ambiance et cetera
il ya un débat très ouvert contrairement
à ce qu'on dit et puis on peut changer
d'avis comme vous m'avez fait changer
d'avis parfois un sur tel ou tel point
parce que les argumentations son le son
sont bonnes il ya un débat ouvert et
dans la mesure en plus où il ya les qpc
ça serait tragique que on en fait d'une
institution où il y aurait des
expressions
dissidente qui serait vite de nature
politique et ça je crois qu'il faut
éviter ça à tout prix si on veut que le
conseil constitutionnel
acquiert encore plus moi il a acquis je
crois à cayres encore plus de
reconnaissance
par l'ensemble de la nation
merci monsieur le président merci chers
collègues pour cet échange
nous allons maintenant quitter cette
salle médicis pour rejoindre la salle de
commission et procédé à notre vote d'où
il ressortira que vous aurez ou non vos
lettres de créance pour le conseil
constitutionnel chers collègues
voilà pour cette audition de jean
jacques hyest sénateurs les républicains
et là était longtemps le président de la
commission des lois au sénat et il a
donc le candidat de gérard allard chez
pour siéger au conseil constitutionnel a
priori eh bien cela ne devrait pas poser
problème puisque les sénateurs devraient
en tout cas là je mens approuvé cette
nomination
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 16h30 je
vous retrouve pour la séance qui sera
notamment consacré à la vente des
mistral très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires